now the saudi crown prince is accused of
dispatching a group of hit men
to kill a former top saudi intelligence
official saad al-jabari who is in
exile in canada now the allegation has
been revealed in a lawsuit
filed by al-jabari in washington d.c the
hitmen were allegedly sent by muhammad
bin salman just
days after journalist jamal khashoggi
was murdered inside the saudi consulate
in istanbul
in october 2018. now they failed to get
past the borders
at toronto's airport but the lawsuit
alleges that algebraia's life remains
in dire peril al jabari is seeking
damages from the crown prince for
allegedly
orchestrating an attempted judicial
killing and
for violating international law well for
more let's now speak to our
correspondent mike hannah who's in
washington dc
mike just what do we know about what's
in this lawsuit
well along with what you said in the
introduction there the case has been
issued here in the district court in dc
assad al-jabri was believed to have had
strong connections to u.s
intelligence he served as a senior
official in saudi arabia for a long
period of time
and then left that country back in may
2018
and went to turkey first and then canada
where he took up residence
in october as you mentioned he received
warnings it is said
that a saudi hit squad was after him
this is at the same time as jamal
khashoggi
was murdered in istanbul once again he
immediately took steps to try and
protect himself and his family
but the hit squad known as the tiger
squad according to the court papers
was denied entry at the pearson airport
they were turned back
but what has subsequently happened is
that two of his children
were detained in saudi arabia and they
are still being held there according to
the court papers
which in what is described as human bait
to lure him out so that the saudi
government can deal with them mike this
was all filed in the u.s
rather than in canada can you talk us
through why and where this goes from
here
well it's been fired in the u.s uh
predominantly because
of albari's ties to
u.s intelligence also in his court
papers
there is a lot about saudi u.s relations
which does
have an immediate uh uh context
in terms of being filed here in
washington dc
but what he is doing is seeking
unspecified damages
from the crown prince and certainly this
is going to be a
long case obviously the crown prince is
going to deny
these allegations as will his legal
representatives
but the court will be looking at all the
details at this
very very long and very detailed court
proceeding that has been brought before
them
albari as i said seeking some form of
unspecified damages from the crown
prince
uh for potential injury to himself and
of course
a injury that has already happened to
members of his family according to the
court filings
remembering as i said that two of his
children are still being detained
in saudi arabia mike hannah there in
washington dc with all those details for
us thank you very much mike
well we can now also speak to imad hab
he's the director of research and
analysis at the arab center washington
dc and he joins us now
on skype from there iman let me start by
asking are we seeing a pattern emerge
here
of course we are uh unfortunately this
is
uh the you know these these are
unfortunately as uh resorted to before
uh we know of this uh
murder we also know that a lot of people
inside saudi arabia are either thrown in
jail or
uh disappeared so it's it's
it is very very plausible very possible
that he would he would do something like
this
but you know at what price this is the
problem the price is the reputation of
the kingdom of saudi arabia
uh you know if if he cannot stand uh
some criticism or things of that nature
it's it's very very tough to root a
kingdom uh with uh with this kind of uh
record imad as you say we do know what
happened with jamal khashoggi just how
many other dissidents are in the same
position potentially being targeted
abroad
i i personally do not have necessarily a
uh actual number but i know that there
are women and men
all over the world in germany and france
and the united
states in canada who have really
basically run away from saudi arabia
because they are afraid of
repercussions from the government and
which is
now and totally in the hands of muhammad
bin salman
so we we i mean it's it's unfortunate
it's it's really
that's the only thing i can say i don't
think saudi arabia deserves to really
have this this kind of reputation you
mentioned some reputational damage there
for riyadh i mean this is a lawsuit
filed in the u.s
what's the significance of that could we
potentially see some political fallout
here
in the relationship between riyadh and
washington dc
yeah this is this is uh this is really
serious
uh uh you know your reporter from
washington just uh
mentioned that maybe al-jabri thinks
that
that since he has connections to
american intelligence services he
probably has a better chance
here in the united states but honestly i
mean you know uh
he has a better chance no matter what in
the united states because the united
states government
and specific uh democrats in the in the
congress
are really demanding a lot of change in
saudi policy uh towards its people
towards
the yemen towards uh dissidents uh so
uh uh he does uh this is the as far as
i'm concerned this is a very smart move
to start to do this in in washington
uh because specifically there is a
political uh
uh support so to speak to a case of this
sort
well let me ask you then how this might
be being viewed in saudi arabia
how is mbs being viewed especially in
the wake of
khashoggi's murder are you kidding i
mean uh he
he should really eat what's uh what's
what's happening in the united states
regarding saudi arabia
uh the uh you know we we don't
necessarily 100 percent know what's
going to happen after november 3rd the
presidential election but
it's likely that joe biden is going to
come to the white house and it's likely
that the democrats are going to take
control of both
the congress uh chambers of congress the
uh how the representatives and the
senate so
uh he better really try to
amend so to speak uh his uh his record
uh
he better really know that what is what
what might be coming may not be
necessarily uh to his liking
from the arab center washington dc
always great to get your insights here
on al jazeera emma thank you for being
with me